the goddess of death destroyed your
hammer like a piece of glass
[Applause]
before you queen the entire universe was
in jail
and putting together a team to stop us
made of rocks you don't need to be
afraid unless you're made of scissors
everybody this is gonna be my thor
ragnarok video for all the deleted
scenes the alternate post-credit scene
that they shot and then cut there were
even a few deleted subplots in a
character they got wholesale just cut
out of the movie a really big comic book
character so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get everything I'm still doing that
ticket giveaway I'll explain at the end
of the video obviously just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
yet we'll be talking about specific plot
points so the first one is the Odin
scene that they change they cut a whole
bunch of Odin out of the movie you may
have seen those behind the scenes
pictures of him looking like a hobo
coming to the movie he's wearing that
white jacket and then he dies in short
order so there's like this whole thing
where you don't see him break out of
that old folks home before they tear it
down the trailer moment that everybody
noticed was the hammer destruction scene
so it seemed like it was happening in a
back alley but it happened in this field
it was really part of two different
moments that were changed but it was all
meant to be part of this larger Odin on
earth storyline originally they were
going to find a homeless dirty looking
version of Odin who would be
pontificating to a big group of homeless
people just being a king of the back
alleys like doing his Odin thing albeit
as a homeless person and it was gonna be
kind of a funny joke like oh the king of
Asgard is now the king of the homeless
people the main reason why that got
changed is because the director said
that it felt really depressing to see
Odin like this and they wanted something
a little more dignified as he went out
so they also changed the hammer
destruction same because hella breaks
out right after Odin dies so if he died
in the back alley she would have broke
it out in the back alley so that's why
you saw this in the really early
trailers and then it got moved to the
field later on but part of the other
reason for moving Odin was is because
they wanted to be less distracting just
the really loud city sounds of New York
City and it sort of distracted from the
moment that they were having with Odin
so changing it also provided the
opportunity for Odin to tease that this
would be a great place for a new Asgard
so hopefully they'll follow up on that
in the next Thor film the big alternate
post-credit scene was actually for the
Grand Master so in the one you saw in
the movie he's being confronted
by the revolution and he tries to pass
it off like he helped them come to this
conclusion like he's trying to save his
own life but the alternate version of
that was him in topaz sneaking away on
Thor ship at the end of the movie and
then sort of pushing their way to the
front of the crowd without anybody
calling attention to them in some funny
comment about earth and having to lay
low so obviously they intended to tell
you that he survived the end of the
movie but hopefully he'll pop back up in
a future film but I think they just
wanted to avoid any confusion with the
Thanos post-credit scene they didn't
want to cross those two characters over
too soon but they wound up cutting out a
big comic book character I've talked
about this before beta ray bill was
originally in the movie as a character
he had scenes it was in the arena that's
why his face is on the side of the arena
because he used to be one of the
champions before the hope became the
champion but they said that it was such
a brief moment that Kevin Feige made the
executive decision so they would cut him
out and they would save him for a future
movie when they could actually do a lot
of beta ray bill so he implied in saying
that that they would do beta ray bill at
some point there was a Thor Valkyrie
romance subplot that was cut out
wholesale there was a Valkyrie scene
that was cut out where she just has this
woman leaving her bedchamber and it was
just meant to give you some context for
her character that she loves both women
and men Tessa Thompson also clarified
that the blonde Valkyrie that died
saving her and that flashback scene was
her lover so the director also said that
there was a funny flashback scene for
Thor that they'll save for a future
movie just because it didn't work with
the story they were trying to tell where
Valkyrie remembers Thor from their
childhood and you flashback and Thor's
like this chubby little kid like he used
to be fat when he was a little kid and
it was gonna be this funny thing like
this big strong Asgardian God used to be
this chubby little kid the main reason
why they cut that out is because they
needed Valkyrie to not know Thor the
first time that they meet so he's like
maybe we'll work it into a future film
remember how much everyone went crazy in
the first Avengers film when hook
punched Thor out of frame they had a
version of that on the Rainbow Bridge
where Hulk punches Loki out of frame
like you know they did the thing where
he thrashes Hulk around in the arena huh
now you know how it feels because he did
it to Loki the reversal to that was that
Loki was the one this
that got punched out of frame but it was
also kind of a gross Hulk scene where
he's eating what looks like this giant
strand of spaghetti just like slurping
it into his mouth as Thor's trying to
talk to him and you find that once he
gets to the end of the piece of
spaghetti that it's actually like this
living creature that's wiggling around
as it goes down his throat there was a
whole bunch of hella stuff that was cut
out
I know people wanted to see a flashback
with her Odin just going around the
kingdoms conquering everyone when she's
explaining the true history of Asgard
the big ones though were mostly her just
killing people in present day so there's
a scene where she walks into the throne
room in this standing around all these
dead as guardians there was a scene
where she actually kills them all but
they felt that was redundant so they
just cut it out you just get the idea
she kills pretty much everybody and then
one of the other trailer moments that
they cut out was with everybody standing
on the bridge together facing hella in
that final battle but for the most part
the other deleted scenes that they cut
out were just alternate takes of jokes
that they did like they would do a lot
of improvisation so they would try
different types of jokes in different
moments like with Thor is telling the
story of his hammer to court for the
first time and it's just meant to be
this funny exchange where Thor explains
how much the hammer means to him without
saying so outright they spend a whole
bunch of time on scenes like that just
doing different types of jokes just
trying to find the most funny thing that
they could do so most of that stuff
should make it onto the DVD but I know
everybody wants to see beta ray bill no
idea if that'll make it onto the DVD
because they actually shot footage and
probably cut some special effects for it
and they just cut it out of one of the
final versions of the film but let me
know in the comments what was your
favorite deleted scene that you want
them to add back into the final cut of
the film what will happen is is there's
a whole bunch of Justice League in
infinity war stuff that's gonna be
happening really soon so between that
and the Punisher I'll just try to keep
posting updates on the video schedule as
I post new videos but because the
embargoes up I can also post my
non-spoilery Punisher season 1 review so
that'll happen tomorrow morning there's
a new round of the IMAX ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video congratulations to the winner from
the last video atom man up please
private message me so I can get your
contact details you can click here for
all my Thor Ragnarok Easter eggs and you
can click here for the brand new agents
shield season 5 trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight